bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle vidéo dédiée à ce marvel et
accessoirement la fin de miss marvel je
suis désolé effectivement la vidéo aura
mis du temps à arriver mais écoutez avec
les annonces du comicon et bien tout a
été un peu chamboulé je vous avais écrit
pas mal de choses en rapport avec la
phase 5 à la fin de la phase 4 désormais
tout a été officialisée ce genre de
choses et c'est avec les annonces du
comicon il faut désormais les prendre en
compte aussi
donc j'ai dû réécrire pas mal d'éléments
de la vidéo et du coup bah voila quoi
c'est pourquoi sera mis un petit peu de
temps à venir et pour celles et ceux qui
aimeraient savoir toutes les nouveautés
bas je vous laisserai voir la dernière
vidéo où nous résumons un peu tout ça
donc écouter ne tardons pas plus
longtemps c'est une vidéo simple et
chill où nous allons parler de the
marvel et de la fin de miss marvel il ya
plein de choses intéressantes a souligné
il ya plein d'éléments a théorisé et du
coup bah écoutez bas c'est parti à
l'origine the marvel c'était censé être
captain marvel 2 avec les nouveaux
projets et les nouveaux personnages
marvel a remanié sa en ce marvel zh un
film qui va regrouper trois super
héroïne et du coup bas pour faire cette
production il faut assembler les
ingrédients pour former le plat
effectivement essayons de voir ça comme
si nous étions en cuisine la phase 4
sert à introduire les concepts les
nouvelles thématiques les nouveaux
personnages comme monica ou kamala puis
la phase 5 c'est la confection du plat
avec des films proposant des réunions de
super héros et c'est le cas avec ce
marbles d'ailleurs si vous regardez bien
la plupart des productions de la phase 5
seront des réunions de personnages bref
essayons du coup de voir ce que nous
avons sous la main pour former le plat
le film the marvel
captain marvel après in game et à
retourner dans l'espace on rappelle
qu'elle a toujours son objectif de
modifier lempire cris par rapport à
leurs mensonges et leurs objectifs
concernant les skrulls scroll dont elle
semble toujours chercher le foyer
puisque talos et sa femme étaient sur
terre pendant les événements de far from
home et qu'en plus de cela nick fury est
désormais dans l'espace dans un vaisseau
accompagné de scroll après peut-être que
tout ça a déjà été réglé on rappelle
quand même que le film de captain marvel
se déroule dans les années 90 mais bon
nous n'avons jamais eu de réponse
concernant cela à l'écran et puis vu que
les thématiques fortes de captain marvel
sont les cris et les skrulls la logique
voudrait que ce marvel nous conte une
continuité de ces histoires mais nous
allons revenir plus en détails là dessus
plus tard pour continuer sur les
ingrédients et bien miss marvel et
monica rambo ont toutes les deux été
introduite et la finalité dans leur
histoire c'est que chacune est désormais
lié à carole permettant donc de les
introduire pour se marrent belle monica
après one la vision a été approché des
scroll pour aller rejoindre nick fury
dans l'espace grâce aux skrull caché sur
terre nick fury c'est tout ce qu'il se
passe sur terre du coup étant donné que
le shield et le sword sont plus ou moins
relier fiori a dû être mis au courant
des agissements des ward par rapport au
soir et un monica sans oublier également
le fait que monica a des pouvoirs
maintenant et cela n'a pas dû lui
échapper
concernant miss marvel j'étais plutôt
curieux de savoir comment il allait
relier kamala avec ce marvel car voilà
de par sa famille sa scolarité sa
jeunesse il n'y a aucune chance qu'elle
aille de son plein gré dans l'espace et
de l'autre côté aucune raison pour
carole de revenir sur terre elle n'a
plus rien à faire là bas et en plus ces
deux seuls proches sur terre sont
désormais dans l'espace nick fury et
monica donc voila vous voyez ce que je
veux dire et c'est là que les magouilles
de marvel studios interviennent les
réécritures qui vont avec énormément de
choses ont été modifiées et où ont
fusionné 1 concernant ce que nous
apporte la série miss marvel par rapport
aux comics déjà tout simplement le cas d
inhumain vous le savez tous kamala ainsi
que cam ranh également sont d'origine
inhumaine on va éviter de trop se
plonger dans l'histoire complexe d
inhumain des comics mais la série miss
marvel regrouper tout ce qu'il fallait
pour les introduire les origines flot de
kamal à un gène bizarre dans son corps
quelque chose qui va réveiller son
pouvoir comme le coût de la brume
terrigènes une brume qui réveille le
pouvoir d inhumain en gros un peu plus
tôt dans l'année on avait dr strange de
avec la présence de black bolt le roi d
inhumain dans la terre 838 et puis
également tout le bail des dimensions je
vous le mentionne rapidement dans chaque
vidéo car j'aimerais me focaliser là
dessus dans une vidéo dédiée mais la
phase 4 ce n'est pas seulement le
multivers et les incursions il y a
clairement aussi l'exploration et la
mise en lumière des dimensions chan chee
introduite à l'eau et possiblement les
mcluhan cléa nous ramène la dimension
noir miss marvel nous amène la dimension
nour dr strange introduit le gab jonshon
la dimension entre les univers bref tout
pouvait introduire les inhumains mais
marvel studios a fait un virage à 90
effectivement miss marvel serait plutôt
une sorte de mutante classique comme on
les connaît oui je parle bien des x men
est notamment dû au fait que ce serait
la seule de sa famille en gros à
posséder ce gène qui a réveillé ses
pouvoirs amir son frère n'a pas de
pouvoir lui par exemple et si nous
étions dans les inhumains ce serait un
petit peu bizarre que miss marvel kamala
et ses pouvoirs mais pas son frère amir
également il ya le thème de x-men 97
lors de la révélation de bruno acama la
concernant sa mutation washington
x-men 97 qui d'ailleurs reviendra sur
dix n'est plus en tout beau tout neuf
l'année prochaine et puis on n'oublie
pas que le gène mutant se révèle très
souvent lors de l'adolescence et c'est
ce qui arrive à kamala bref si on
relativise ce n'est pas tant que ça
étonnant que marvel studios est
effectuée cette réécriture en 2017 une
série in humans est sorti et vous le
savez tous ça a été un four la série
habib et comme jamais et rien que ça je
pense que ça a joué et bien évidemment
elle n'est pas canon du coup mais
également il y à l'argument que le mc us
se complexifie énormément c'est un
reproche qui est fait régulièrement à
l'univers depuis la série law qui il
faut s'accrocher et vu toutes les
productions que marvel sort avec
l'arrivée de disney plus il y a
désormais beaucoup de contenu à suivre
et c'est un point intéressant car
beaucoup d'oeuvres simplifie désormais
les concepts donc voilà faire fusionner
on va dire les inhumains avec les
mutants bon c'est un moyen de simplifier
un poil l'univers et le rendre plus
accessible pour des fans un petit peu
plus lambda et enfin il reste un
argument très très important c'est que
disney et par extension du coup marvel
studios a racheté la fox et il ne faut
pas l'oublier la fox détenait les x men
ou encore les quatre fantastiques est
bon il va falloir les intégrer au bout
d'un moment et c'est quelque chose qui
est déjà en marche reed richards est
apparu dans dr strange 2 un film quatre
fantastiques est en production pour la
phase 6 il y à des rumeurs sur l'arrivée
de doctor doom dans l'année donc voilà
il faut faire la même chose avec le gène
mutant et par extension les x men même
si voilà il y encore du temps et rien
n'est vraiment fixé charles xavier et
dans doctor strange 2 maintenant il faut
continuer et intégrer les mutants dans
l'univers 616 et puis bon certains
puristes pourraient me dire également
que miss marvel était voué à devenir une
mutante lors de sa création mais qu'à
cause des problèmes de droit a vu que le
personnage a été créé il n'y a pas si
longtemps dans l'histoire des comics ils
se sont rabattus sur les inhumains bref
c'est du détail mais en tout cas voilà
même avec tout ce que j'ai dit n'oubliez
pas que l'on ne sait rien véritablement
un marvel est toujours capable de nous
la mettre à l'envers et intégrée
finalement les inhumains il faut quand
même rester un poil sur ses gardes bon
du coup parlons un peu de la scène post
générique de miss marvel et du coup du
contenu de the marvel zh je vais tenter
de vous apporter ma vision personnelle
des choses car il ya des éléments qui
sont explicables par rapport à la fin de
miss marple et cetera mais dans le fond
il y a très très peu d'informations
concernant ce marvel donc actuellement
nous sommes un peu libre d'imaginer ce
que l'on veut par rapport aux films
marvel studios a décidé de relier kamala
et carole par le biais du bracelet de la
jeune héroïne et l'idée est pas mal
c'était plutôt perturbant de voir kamala
et carole et changer de place mais il y
a une explication en fait dans les
comics il existe un artefact qui permet
de faire ce genre de choses ce sont les
bracelet relié à la zone négative
ces bracelets sont des reliques de
lempire cris fabriqué il y à des
milliers d'années le captain marvel les
aura en sa possession mais finira piégés
dans la zone négative à cause de la zone
négative c'est en gros une sorte de
dimension adjacente à la terre où
règnent l'antimatière un comics plus
tard un terrien du nom de rick jones que
les amateurs de comics connaissent
sûrement va faire la découverte d'une
autre paire de ces mêmes bracelet qui
ont piégé le captain marvel grâce à
cette découverte marvel va pouvoir et
changer de place avec rick johnson le
transférant donc dans la zone négative
et permettant au héros de revenir sur la
terre nous retrouvons exactement le même
délire dans la série de miss marvel si
ce n'est qu'en plus lorsque najma et
aïcha trouve le bracelet en 1942 ce
dernier est sur le poignet d'un cadavre
de couleur bleue je pense qu'il est
inutile de vous faire un dessin il
s'agit à très très fortes chances d'un
cadavre de cris ce qui confirmerait donc
que le bracelet et possiblement de même
origine et c'est là où je vous disais
qu'il faut se méfier de marvel studios
et qu'ils sont encore capables de nous
la mettre à l'envers car les crises sont
ceux qui ont créé et donner naissance
aux inhumain même s'il y a des chances
que les mutants classique et les
inhumains et fusionnée dans l'univers
616 des films pour une certaine
réécriture et bien il est toujours
possible que les inhumains soit
introduite par la symbolique du brass
l'écrit détenus par kamal a mais en tout
cas dans le fond c'est un élément qui
permet la liaison avec captain marvel
car comme on le disait au début
l'intriguent finale du film captain
marvel c'est que carole souhaite faire
le ménage dans l' empire cris et
remettre de l'ordre
et c'est là où nous allons possiblement
pouvoir nous amusé à imaginer certaines
choses et théoriser un petit peu mais
déjà il faut que nous rajoutions la
dernière pièce de l'édifice de marvel
c'est la série secretin vdn et oui car
comme vous le savez nick fury est le
plus grand allié terriens de carole et
ce dernier sera dans le film the marvel
sans compter le fait que fiori est
désormais relié aux skrulls donc voilà
la série secretin vdn est intéressante
des jacaré sort juste avant le film de
marvel ce donc il est fort à parier que
le grand final de la série va
certainement nous tease est un élément
fort du film à venir cependant il ya
d'autres choses intéressantes a souligné
déjà l'information comme quoi secretin
les jeunes se déroulerait pendant le
blitz c'est à dire les cinq années où
50% de l'univers était absent à cause du
snap de thanos cela paraît très bizarre
car secretin les jeunes est censé être
la série qui met nick fiori au devant de
la scène sauf que nick fury pendant le
blitz bas il était absent car il a fait
partie des disparus libre à vous de
croire ou non s'il ya eu des magouilles
avec talent hausse dans le sens où ce
dernier aurait pris la place de nick
fury et que ce soit à l'eau ce qui est
disparu à la place de fiori mais
personnellement je n'y crois pas
vraiment je pense en réalité que si la
série secretin v jeunes se déroule
pendant le blitz c'est avant tout pour
la mise en contexte de l'histoire ce que
je veux dire par là c'est qu'après une
game one la vision nous a introduit le
sword et far from nous a dévoilé que
nick fiori après son retour dans endgame
est parti dans l'espace accompagné des
skrulls mais en soit nous ne savons pas
grand-chose de plus concernant fiori et
c'est certainement ça que marvel
souhaite développer avec secretin vdn le
truc c'est que déjà le bleeps et la
période parfaite pour que des scroll
malveillants entre guillemets arrive sur
terre et se fonde parmi la masse bah oui
fiori le fondateur du shield et une
grande partie de ses associés ont
disparu à cause du snap l'hérault
restants étaient focalisés sur la
disparition des gens et sur leurs
cuisants échecs face à tan hausse qui en
plus a détruit les pierres donc voilà en
plus de cela dans one la vision nous
avons appris que maria rambo avait lancé
le sword et que malheureusement cette
dernière est décédé pendant le clip
laissant hayward reprendre le contrôle
de l'âge ans sauf que marié rambo ii par
les événements du film captain marvel
est désormais une proche de nick fury et
c'est sûr à 100% qu'ils ont lancé le
projet ensemble même si nick a
malheureusement disparu à cause du snap
laissant maria gérer le sword tout seul
et c'est là où développer la période du
blip est intéressante car après une game
et après rwanda vision nick fury est
parti dans l'espace et c'est notamment
grâce aux soins qui s'est largement
développée depuis je le rappelle comme
ça mais le shield qui signifie bouclier
c'est la défense face aux menaces
externes les menaces spatiale en gros
tandis que le sword qui signifie et pc
plutôt un complément en mode la
meilleure défense c'est l'attaqué nick
fury part directement sur le terrain des
menaces c'est à dire l'espace pour mieux
prévenir celles qui arrivent sur terre
d'ailleurs étant donné que wendat vision
se déroule quelques semaines après
endgame et far from home un an plus tard
cela veut dire que monica rambo devrait
se trouver dans le même vaisseau que
nick fury et qu'elle va possiblement
revenir dans secretin les jeunes bref on
divague un petit peu du sujet de base
mais pour résumer en gros il ya de
fortes chances que secretin v jeunes
développent un petit peu la période du
blip avant de revenir dans le présent
soit après far from home pour amener du
coup le film de marvel bon et maintenant
pour revenir clairement sur le film the
marvel il faut que je vous parle pour
moi de ce qui pourrait être l'élément
clé du film
et du coup il s'agirait de novare il y à
des rumeurs comme quoi ce personnage
apparaît très enfin à l'écran et je vous
avoue que pour moi concernant ce marvel
c'est presque peut-être une nécessité
novarra l'origine c'est un cris
provenant d'un autre univers en gros ce
dernier par le biais de son vaisseau
s'est perdu dans le multivers et en
tentant de rentrer chez lui il a
finalement atterri dans la réalité 616
déjà rien qu'avec ça cela permet
d'amener la thématique du multivers dans
le film la thématique centrale des
nouvelles phases mais le plus
intéressant c'est qu'à la base présenté
comme une menace novare est en fait
quelqu'un de bien même s'il a voulu
confrontée l'humanité novare s'est
finalement mis à la protéger il est
celui qui va devenir le nouveau captain
marvel dans les comics il a aidé les
avengers à plusieurs reprises il est
intervenu pendant l'invasion skrull de
secretin vdn pour aider l'humanité et il
va finalement devenir une figure
emblématique de l'équipe des young
avengers qui nous savons ce forme petit
à petit dans le mca en fait novare c'est
important pour moi de l'intégrer car il
est une belle figure de l' empire cri
avec de bonnes intentions dans le mc eu
depuis toujours on nous présente les
cris comme les menaces de plusieurs
films ils sont ceux qui ont persécuté
les skrulls ils sont les antagonistes du
film de captain marvel run and
l'accusateur a été une grande menace
pendant plusieurs productions et d'après
certaines sources il ya de très grandes
chances que l' antagonistes de ce marvel
soit le duo de dirigeants cris
l'empereur heil dan et le général
dardenne novare permet de contrebalancer
tout ça car c'est justement ce qui
permet de complexifier et ajouter de la
matière aux histoires de carole denver
ce lait scroll ne sont pas tous bons
talos et peut-être gentil mais ce n'est
pas le cas de tous et secretin des
jeunes va nous le prouver et inversement
les cris ne sont pas tous mauvais ils
ont simplement un fonctionnement
différent de par leur histoire et leur
empire mais il y a deux bons personnage
parmi eux du coup carroll qui souhaitent
faire le ménage dans l' empire cris et
imposer un nouveau fonctionnement à ce
peuple est bien celle à toutes les
difficultés que nous proposera le film
carole et surpuissante personne chez les
cris peu la confronter va même
l'intelligence suprême qui est censé
être la grande divinité décrit il faut
que la menace du film qui va opposer
carole ne soit pas axé sur la puissance
et le physique mais plutôt sur le mental
et la politique après tout carole n'est
pas vraiment une crise à la base elle
était une humaine alors pourquoi
devrait-elle imposer sa vision au peuple
crie juste parce qu'elle est
surpuissante et bien c'est là où c'est
intéressant la série miss marvel nous a
démontré que le bracelet de kamala et
très certainement reliés à l'histoire
décrit comme je vous disais dans les
comics ce bracelet et notamment reliées
à un autre et qu'il est également liée à
la zone négative il est sûr que le mca
va réadapter tout ça mais à quoi
pouvons-nous nous attendre exactement il
est possible que carole était coincé
dans la zone négative ou pourquoi pas la
dimension nour introduite dans miss
marvel la phase 4 explore largement les
dimensions adjacentes comme je le disais
donc c'est possible mais ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir la réaction de
carole quand l échange de places avec
kamal à elle regarde ses mains puis elle
regarde l'environnement et elle semble
inquiète quand elle comprend qu'elle est
dans la chambre d'une terrienne fan
d'elle peut être car à cause d'elle
kamala est désormais en danger mais
surtout nous ne savons pas s'il ya des
conséquences sur le fait que les deux
femmes et changent de place nous n'avons
aucune réponse pour le moment mais
carole contrairement à d'habitude à
halle et brad découvert et de gants avec
des bracelets sur les mains nin qu'elle
regarde après son arrivée peut-être que
ce sont des artefacts liés au bracelet
qui sait ou peut-être que ce sont
simplement des éléments de sa nouvelle
tenue bref on ne sait pas quoi mais du
coup ce que je voulais dire à la base
c'est que peut-être que les change de
place et changent également les pouvoirs
ce qui permettrait à kamala de survivre
si carole était au milieu d'un conflit
et en même temps cela permettrait à
denver ce de se retrouver bloqué sur
terre et du coup la forcer à aller à la
rencontre de nick fury et monica qui
sont retournés sur terre
de secretin vdn pour gérer l'invasion
skrull et pourquoi pas novare s'il est
déjà introduit et du coup repartir dans
l'espace avec un vaisseau du sword pour
sauver kamala et régler le conflit de
base de carole nous aurions face à nous
les retrouvailles que nous attendons
tous nous aurions également une alliance
cris skrull avec novare et les équipiers
de fiori nous aurions une intrigue où la
puissance de carole serait diminuée pour
qu'elle soit égal avec les autres
personnages nous aurions une kamala qui
serait enfin ce que ça fait d'être dans
la peau de son héroïne préférée et enfin
avec la possible mort des dirigeants
cris nous aurions un possible nouveau
souverain cris a lié à la terre et par
extension à nick fury et captain marvel
je parle bien évidemment de novare
bon et du coup voilà je pense que l'on
va s'arrêter là étant donné mon retard
concernant la fin de la série miss
marvel je me suis dit que ça aura été
pas mal de pourquoi pas faire une vidéo
un petit peu plus globale réunissant
tous les éléments qui va composer le
film se marrent veines du cou à la fin
de miss marvel wendat vision avec monica
rambo captain marvel un engament
secretin vagues jaunes etc etc on soit
tout est possible car on a très peu
d'informations pour le moment et on est
un peu libre d'imaginer ce que l'on veut
nous avons clairement le temps on n'a
pas assez d'information et puis la fin
de miss marvel est quand même assez flou
c'est très dur de bien lire ce que
marvel veut nous montrer d'ailleurs je
ne voulais pas dit dans la vidéo mais
j'aimerais le calais comme ça à la fin
mais je trouverais ça pas mal que
si marvel studio décide de véritablement
amené la zone négative ce serait bien
que ce soit un élément qui puisse
contrer carole kamala et monica
effectivement vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que les trois femmes ont des
pouvoirs relié à la lumière du coup ce
serait pas mal qu'il y ait quelque chose
relié à l'obscurité comme la zone
négative par exemple pour contrer du
coup les pouvoirs de carole monica et
kamal a enfin bref c'est une idée comme
ça je voulais juste le calais comme ça
avant la fin de la vidéo sur ce j'espère
que ces dernières vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à me le faire savoir via
l'espace commentaires n'hésitez pas non
plus à laisser un beau pouces bleus et
n'hésitez pas surtout à vous abonner à
la chaîne pour ne pas louper les
prochaines vidéos et puis écouter bah
voilà c'était argot rock que le
lionheart soit avec vous allez ciao tout
le monde
[Musique]